so I've titled this control go
prediction Plus Engineering I think this
is the grammar that I use to think about
these sorts of questions I have an
amazing post-doctoral associate in my
lab who's here who I sat down and he
said I didn't know you worked on causal
inference right and I said uh well you
know you know we looks like we have a
lot to know about each other but I think
we're going to use the grammar of kind
of prediction which is largely what we
use in The evolutionary and
bioengineering paradigms which is the
ones in which the ones in which I
operate today uh before doing anything
else really I want to acknowledge the
organizers of this meeting everybody who
supported this this is one of the
coolest and most interesting Gatherings
I've been at in my several years at at
Yale I always say that this institution
needs more kind of renegade nerd
Gatherings there's not enough and this
is absolutely qualifies as one so I
appreciate uh everyone who supported and
all of you of course for attending all
of the individuals in my research
program all the individuals who
supported this work in various ways
through the years and of course a large
library of mentors mentees former
mentees who are now mentors people who
now support me in various ways they've
influenced this work uh in various ways
through the years and my newest uh
family is Santa Fe Institute which has
really been important for integrating
this dimension of my research program
and further my identity uh for asking
questions that are related to what we're
discussing here at this Workshop today
so I want to make sure they are
acknowledged um you know I the reason
why I titled the talk to my title came
from some popular writing I was actually
writing the article on the top where I
actually in introduced this really just
conceptual framework for thinking about
how we're uh thinking about controlling
evolutionary biology in various settings
largely in the construction of
biomolecules um and I came up with this
framework uh control equals prediction
uh control equals prediction Plus
Engineering it's really just a like I
said it's a conceptual anchor for how to
think about how we're where right the
types of information we need to be able
to control a complex biological system
right and I kind of use this as an
anchor for the rest of this talk but
mostly we're going to be focusing on the
on the prediction component of this
since that's kind of the one related not
the same as but related to causality um
how do I enter these problems well I
mean I think by my basic science program
I've been described as a lot of
different things I give a talk of many
different sorts of scientific audiences
so depending on who I'm around is who
the way I'm described uh but comp
ational biologists mostly and we use a
range of methods where we we use disease
to ask fundamental questions kind of
about the way nature works and I think
on the flip side we use kind of theory
in various paradigms that potentially
improve how we think about disease uh
and epidemics but I think there's
another component of my research program
which is going to be very very active
here today and I think uh it is that
active really in all areas of my program
uh and that's kind of the intersection
between uh data and culture I think I
this is something that began as
something something that I was doing for
you know just just because this has
actually become a real technical
Paradigm for my work and I think it
dances very right intimately with uh
some of the other dimensions of my work
so you'll be introduced this as well but
I think really there's been a
combination between these identities
recently right like I said which is and
I think really where I land is that I
focus on how interactions shape
constraints in biological systems okay
so whether we're talking about
engineered systems or we're talking
about artificial systems or
informational systems I mean really you
can Define
uh you we can Define all of them by what
are the guard rails around them what are
the things that are actually shaping how
those systems are constructed in my
sense the way things evolve these
interactions shape uh a molecular
Evolution right they constrain how
epidemics manifest and they constrain
science in the world which isn't all in
which it is embedded so this is really
how I can frame like I call myself an
interaction nerd I like when I put
things together and I get something
surprising and I kind of use biological
systems to be able to ask those sorts of
questions okay now right when we think
about what a constraint is I think this
manifests in all the talks that we heard
we heard this outstanding just just this
morning we've heard about different
constraints in the way they shape the
systems of Interest be they cosmological
be they anthropological be they cellular
be they biophysical we can think about a
lot of ways and so this is like one
dimension of constraint where I mostly
live I I study proteins and I study kind
of protein folding and here you have an
enzyme right dihydro reductase you know
basically it catalyzes a reaction at
different rates and different
temperatures right so in this situation
right temperature is a context which is
kind to constraining what this enzyme
can do and in my lab we identify kind of
the way this constrains the way it
evolves it sets the expectations for the
way this sort of protein evolves we can
think about constraint this way many you
work on the kind of ecosystem ecology
scale or the if you think about climate
change you think about species
distribution or any kind of really even
this is in many ways geopolitical all
right you can think about forces
operating on this uh level some of us
kind of live in this level here me less
so right this is any New Yorkers in the
audience this is the Queens bridge okay
good this is the Queensbridge houses so
this is the largest public housing
complex in the United States now and
it's home to all my heroes from growing
up and I think one of the great question
is you know what what is it about
neighborhoods like this that give birth
to so many people gifted with words in
terms of hip-hop artists right and this
is something that was very very
important to me we think about this in a
lot of context so what is it about this
these sets of constraints and contexts
that kind of created that opportunity
for that sort of linguistic uh
advancement but then of course this one
right these constraints are tied
together it's not different than when we
heard about scales right I think there's
resonance between these things um
there's there there's a relationship
between some of those constraints we
talked about for example like that
constraint that relates to that
constraint but this constraint of course
in this context of course did not grow
out of the ground this one came out
because of constraints like this
historical constraints okay like there
were active decisions made by Homo
sapiens about who could live where and
who could be how how you treat certain
people and what have you so the point is
that all areas of my research program
and all areas of all the things we're
discussing here in this right with
regation to causation and inference
they're being shaped by various forces
okay and so what I'm going to argue is
that right the success if you will or
the effectiveness of causal inference
and or in my case prediction or control
is really going to be grounded by right
our understanding of the way these sorts
of constraints influence our systems of
Interest our understanding of them our
ability to parameterize them right and
that really is right that that's kind of
the framework that I approach these
sorts of questions with and so we'll
meet various components of these in
various actors now I'm not nearly smart
enough to study this and this well
enough there's there's people have
studied this for centuries infinitely
better than I ever could but I have
found the the the attempt to do so right
to attempt to be the idiot in the room
and right when we reading about that
sort of thing to be refreshing and it
has added to the dimensions uh of my
work in many ways so like I said we're
going to get through a lot right so
we're doing okay all right so control
prediction it's engineering right so
again like I said right these sorts of
constraints are actually shaping our
ability to predict and really they're
shaping the engineering and they shape
our ability to control systems complex
systems of Interest right and today
we're going to talk about two different
systems right genetics and evolution we
got this outstanding talk today that did
a lot of the work for us right so I can
skip a lot of that so thank you for that
Professor um and epidemics these are
both biological quote unquote systems
right and there there have many things
in common so what we're going to do is
we're going to kind of talk about a
little bit of a history of how we think
about prediction and causation in these
Realms very very little history right
we're going to talk about the modern
times like what are the Contemporary
issues and challenges for thinking about
these and then I'm going to hopefully
end with a little bit of like positivity
with regards to new ways for thinking
about how we can think about prediction
more carefully and both of them I'll
introduce a new theorem in the process a
funny theorem in the process so history
and genetics and evolution we can kind
of think about a lot of ways a lot of
really smart David I don't know how you
feel about this but this is a this is
this is kind of one way of right one way
of capturing like the era we've been in
I know it's I think the Modern Age
probably needs a we're kind of like in
some ways we're in the age of genomics
but in some ways we're we're in a
different era um but what we're going to
focus on now is the modern evolutionary
synthesis we got a really really great
primer for that earlier and I think um
importantly right this era is the one
that really transformed kind of biology
into a quantitative field of course as
you know you know everybody who does
Empirical science of any kind has been
profoundly influenced by Fisher's work
right um but really it was about the
fusion of these dornian and melan
schools and kind of formulated Evolution
as a quantitative science capable of
describing and explaining the process of
evolution so pretty much right away when
we got these quantitative tools to be
able to you know potentially treat a
biological system like a physical one
pretty much right away right people went
right to the to you know people got came
up with like these new fundamental ways
to describe how populations work we were
able to describe and understand what had
happened for for Millennia with regards
to artificial selection and Agriculture
and domestication so it's really one of
the most EMP powerful sets of
understandings that we've ever come up
with I think and I will defend that but
of course with that came false
prediction as well and it came some
errors as well right and of course that
right that we could C that in in the
eugenic movement the notion that we can
take these kind of uh discret principles
and apply them to Human population right
right so right so when we think about
this and I think this is this is kind of
the this is the challenge when we're
thinking about how to understand systems
well enough to understand cause and
effect or causal inference or understand
prediction right we there's there's
there's breakthroughs and then there's
questions about what we do with those
tools and then there's kind of techn
technical misgivings that often time
lead to certain problems and we see the
signature for both the Beauty and the
problems of this Paradigm today right so
I mean it's a great time to be in this
profession I think me we're doing all
kind of important things with genomic
technology um you might have saw the the
approval of the first
crisper uh kind of truly crisper uh
driven therapy for Cle cemia that was
just recently approved so I mean it's
really one of the most amazing times to
ever think about you know living systems
in this way right and so we can think
about things like genomic prediction and
we think about genetic engineering in
ways we've never been able to we can
wire organisms mut my mutation with
right in order to kind of get to fenot
types of Interest we can great but of
course with that comes things like this
okay and I don't know we had a
conversation at dinner I want to make
sure I want to make sure I put this in
because this actually I don't know how
many maybe rais hands anybody seen this
film all right I I got a big raise back
there right um well good I I don't have
to feel bad this is this is pretty nerdy
what you're going to say so I actually
wrote a paper about this that made the
cover of genetics right um and the idea
here is we kind of use the film to have
a conversation about this exactly right
the whole thing is how are our
predictive tools doing we use the film
to have a contemporary conversation
about where we are with this sort of
Technology right and we actually review
things like embryo selection right what
are the statistics about it how good are
we how good are we not and they actually
got a lot of things quite right in the
film 25 years ago right so again right
cultural relics and cultural things end
up being this important kind of
substrate for us to be able to think
about the Contemporary technical issu
isues when we're thinking about
causation and prediction okay but of
course there's many other conflicts okay
right many many many others okay so even
things that I par participated in like
the Precision medicine Paradigm the
notion that we can treat every single
individual here according to their
peculiar biology I mean it's just
riddled with a lot of kind of technical
misgivings we've already seen genetic
discrimination happen obviously some of
you are a part of these conversations
about genetically modified technology so
these are these are some of the areas
where despite all these breakthroughs
andc excitement we have a lot of
contemporary questions right about what
it is that we're doing here okay and of
course the rise of extremism and fascism
and race science which of course is
another older right this great goes back
to this goes back to Eugenics but of
course has been
reanimated right so what we talked about
here was kind of this history uh of how
genetics kind of has thought about this
sort of problem and some contemporary
things that we should be very very
excited about and some other things that
we should be very very cautious about I
think the same thing goes for how we
think about the EP epidemics and of
course um you know long long history of
epidemics I'm going to capture it in two
slides but kind of modern Public Health
as we understand it some of you know
this story about kind of the water pump
and it was chalera and it was the
identification of the source being a
water supply is the birth of by many
opinions uh of Public Health as we know
it today and of course mathematical
epidemiology which is one of my
paradigms again can be traced to many of
people there's a long history uh going
back but I think the kind of one of the
modern iterations that some of us I
learned they actually teach in physics
here which I was very very happy to hear
in intro physics here they actually
teach uh dynamical systems uh to the to
the to the to the biology majors and
it's basically this notion of how you
can understand and mathematize a
population um undergoing some kind of
infectious process and this goes back to
1927 okay so again long history doing
that a lot of successes lots of failures
but we can kind of animate that now and
with those contentions and challenges
are with regards to because the point is
when you model something presumably you
understand what its character is such
that you can potentially predict it like
that's the point you want to be able to
understand who you need to vaccinate and
where where you need to intervene and
what have you and I think this of course
has been animated here in case you
haven't been paying attention um and of
course you know the roles of modeling
and what we were predicting and how was
really one of the central conflicts of
right the pandemic air and remains so
and I think uh mathematical minding was
kind of on trial if you will uh in this
sort of way and so it had to kind of we
had to kind of reflect on whether what
what are we modeling how are we modeling
it are we using the right tools what are
the what are the assumptions that we're
making right this ended up being
something very very important that was
essential now in the face of this I did
some mathematical modeling this but most
of my work again we're going to return
why I think this sort of meeting and why
I'm so grateful uh for this sort of
gathering is the multidisciplinarity is
not just nominal it really really you
really actually learn from it you learn
what the important questions are from
engaging because I did a little bit of
this but I did much more of this much
more public engagement I became kind of
a a misinformation Warrior during the
pandemic right so I did some mathematic
and what I what I learned about uh what
I learned about uh the pandemic and the
way we engage it um is there is is that
there are several challenges that I
think that are common to both genetics
and epidemiology right so when you think
about causation and prediction right I
think the ethical is the technical in
some ways right so I think these are
separate paradigms with SE seate
grammars right but part of the
conversation a lot of the things that we
think are ethical are actually right
rooted in technical challenges that we
have right in being able to properly
predict the shape of an epidemic or
being able to proper predict what the
phenotypic effects are of a mutation or
what's in a genome or the relationship
between genome genotype and phenotype
right and um and you know rooted in
right we might be really swell people
but our ideas might be bad right I mean
in in a particular in the genomics
context right you might have good
intentions and I'm not here to judge
anybody's intentions with regards to
being able to predict whether or not
baby A or B will get into Yale or not
you might have good intentions right um
but the ideas that you're using to be
able to kind of you know uh influence
that prediction of course might be bad
and of course this applies very firmly
to a lot of the conversation with
regards to ethical AI right but I was
talking to someone I think you about
time scale yesterday today um the times
SC have consequences and effect on
accountability sometimes the negative
consequences are too Downstream for the
people who are right right so if I'm if
I mispredict an ep the shape of an
epidemic like two years from now and I
come up with a harmful policy right is
that t is that time scale which that's
wrong and causes harm does that match up
with me being held accountable for my
bad decision making upfront right so
this is one of the problems there's not
a lot of there's not a lot of cost for
me getting things wrong I'm making these
incorrect predictions and that sure as
that goes in the genomic context when
you don't see the D you don't see the
consequences for your actions for
Generations so I think there's that
challenge that we have to deal with um
but more than that are we thinking about
complex biological systems correctly
right and this is what we'll we we'll go
next um I have some kind of Frameworks
for how to think about this and so your
understanding the role of constraint
context and shaping we can it can really
help our predictions I think there are
Frameworks and understandings and
Concepts in both genetics and epidemics
that can actually help us kind kind of
weigh through this one of the things I
try to fight through when I think about
these sorts of complex biological
systems with a lot of different
processes of information is to not be
nihilistic right the goal the point is
not that everything is hopelessly
complicated and so we shouldn't bother
maybe some of you think that but like
right that's not where I live I think
it's more about understanding what the
specific roles of those contexts so
we'll talk about these two things what
are some constraints that govern complex
biological systems and genetics we have
Gene by environment interactions you
might have heard that one that one is
reasonably popular uh and that is the
notion that you don't you can't really
tell what the consequences of a gene or
a mutation are doing you need to know
something about the environment you're
in right I think the second one is what
we'll talk briefly about today Gene by
Gene interactions it's a concept called
epistasis and it's a little bit odd so
we'll spend a second there um with
epidemics host parasite interactions I
think anybody that's ever been sick
knows what that means um but host host
interactions is the way that people are
interacting influence the Dynamics and
disease you bet but then there's other
social forces that can interact with how
host right or interact with other hosts
and by extension interacting with
parasites and these are the sorts of
interactions like I said that are
actually shaping these complex
biological systems and by extension
influence right causal chains and
influence predictive uh the possibility
of prediction okay so we'll start with
genetics okay now what and uh now we'll
start with this concept called epistasis
it's been called the dark matter of
biology for the physicist right or the
dark matter of genetics now what is it
exactly this is a great colloquial
definition from a mentor and friend Dan
weinreich a popul a theoretical
population geneticist the surprise at
the phenotype when mutations are
combined given the constituent mutations
individual effects I know what mutation
a does on by itself I know what mutation
B does by itself I put them together and
I get a whoa the surprise and that's
that's like legitimately what it is I
have I have this fun graduate student
analogy I have two extraordinarily
talented graduate students in my lab uh
when they comb by so they these are
their
pointer it's on here
right oh yes right so both of them have
are positive right this is kind of a the
y- axis is just how good they are so
they're extraordinary both of them you
put them together you put them together
experimentally right and you get this um
you get this additive effect right as in
you just add them together when they're
coding together you just extraordinary
kind of nonlinear positive interaction
which means they code together
beautifully but when when I ask them to
write a paper together they actually
like have a negative interaction and
they get less work done together than
either of them would have been done
individually right um and that's really
what we're talking about with mutations
I mean I think they have these sorts of
different sorts of interaction effects
between mutations now why is this
important I mean it's just completely
rewies how we think about the importance
of the individual mutation or Gene in
dictating phenotype if all your genot if
all your phenotypes depend on
interactions between genes and we're
talking about 20,000 and 50,000 and
100,000 genes then the problem I mean
astronomical is too small to think about
how quickly this right combinatorial
explosion creates a mess here right
nless we have some tools the for this
crowd yeah we have we have this the
point of this is just we have a whole
host of to statistical tools to be able
to resolve out higher order interactions
I think I I look around the room and
look all you all have them in fact we've
borrowed this from theoretical computer
science this is the Walsh hadamar
transform which you know comes from you
know noise stuff in engine ing in
computer science but we now apply it to
how we can resolve out and come up with
the algebra basic algebra for how we can
resolve out how epistatic interactions
are occurring between genes um right
right but again this nihilism question
okay is this a nihilistic understanding
if everything has to interact with
everything else isn't that kind of a
hopeless feeling right and but
thankfully there's some new Concepts
with regards to GL to to epistasis that
I think give us rhyme and reason and
that's called Global epistasis this
basically says that there are
fundamental rules governing how those
interactions between those graduate
students happen such that I can
potentially predict them so even though
they're nonlinear and they feel
surprising when it happens there's
actually an underlying physics of kind
of interacting information and this
pioneered by Alvar Sanchez my my close
colleague um and and we've done this
work we've done a bunch of work on this
recently so right uh they they also
often follow systemic patterns that
enable predictability and they right um
and this kind of changes our
relationship with a concept that would
otherwise be nihilistic right we now
have this understanding that wow we can
actually do something about this uh to
understand this phenomenon and now this
is being animated all across kind of
genetics and genomics to add rhyme and
reason to phenoma that seem to undermine
predictability okay sorry all right
right so again Global OB say suggests
that fundamental rules there there's
fundamental rules for these sorts of
interactions such that they can be
predicted and we'll kind of know not to
make them write papers together but they
right now shifting to the epidemic
context right we talked about host
parasite interactions host right we're
going to talk about the sorts of
constraints that influence them and what
are some different ways we can think
about prediction and causation in this
system all right so one of the things
that I've studied is the kind of
mathematical and computational mils of
hepatitis C virus we call this the
silent epidemic for a bunch of reasons
right having to do with the people it
affects it's you people who inject drugs
and now like the natural history of
disease kind of can can can make it
challenging um to understand but
nonetheless it's extremely important
right and so what we did is we actually
took a m we created a mathematical model
that if you looked at if you think about
a disease that's spread by people who
are sharing drug paraphernalia it has
features in common with a vector born
disease right so this exactly what we
did mathematically we um we we basically
uh right published here in 2019 but
there something very important happened
in this work right when we were doing
this work I found myself in Reddit
forums of people who were users right
because I'm trying to understand some
things about the way that the disease is
transmitted and in that I kind of I got
very very guilty because I said here I'm
trying to mathematize something with all
of the social import this is something
that's really really affecting people
okay now right part of the reason why
this became important mathematically is
I began to think and learn more about
the way social forces are actually
crafting the thing that I'm trying to
mathematize okay so that ends up being a
a a a serious and important dimension
for how we're thinking about modeling
and predicting the shape of these
epidemics I can't possibly understand
anything about disease if if I'm not
engaged with the forces that are
actually influencing the hosts okay so
again right uh a reason why to engage
these different disciplines and of
course there's other social forces and I
began to work on this I've working on
this right how how how kind of policy
regarding uh imprison influences the
Dynamics of pandemic in multiple
Dimensions right so what we're seeing
here is right uh in the context of P
epidemiology was right I I'm interested
I have a complex system composed of all
of these elements and and I want to know
uh and I want to know how uh how to
predict it we can think about cause you
know causation in this system and we're
identifying all of these constraints
that influence what those predictions
will be and this paper here is really
one of my favorite it's you know
admittedly by two good friends of mine
but I think it's one of the most
important papers I think I read in in
epidemiology in quite some time and they
introduced this notion from physics
called permutation entropy right which
kind of has this other life but they
apply it to the case of epidemics and
this is what they say here's the model
that we did for Hepatitis C virus and so
we don't you know for those one of the
things Innovations we did is we modeled
needles as their own population and so
we can actually think about what happens
when you take needles out of a
population for example with a safe
injection uh sites or with needle
exchange these sorts of Public Health
interventions that allow you to actually
directly deal with the problem of
needles that was one of the kind of
conceptual Innovations to this
mathematical model what this paper says
is that if you want to predict the
shaping of an epidemic
okay the problem is the parameters
themselves change as the epidemic is
happening right and so you are hopeless
in trying to predict an EP an epidemic
past a few days and of course it'll
depend on disease it'll depend on right
but it introduced kind of this idea that
where you're it really is a fruitless
venture to try to come up with a
universal long-term predictive algorithm
it doesn't work that way because the
parameters are changing too too fast
right and I think this is uh the
Innovation here I think this had a big
effect on me because this is this is the
sort of thing it's not that we can't
predict it's that perhaps we should be
changing our what our goals are for
prediction it's not that we can't
understand causal Chains It's how far
apart they are when we're talking about
the actors and their consequences and
epidemiological systems
okay um and so this is what we mean
about prediction right now um now we
talked about this in various Frameworks
we talked about this with in genetic
systems the sorts of things that both
undermine prediction and genetics but
potentially right there's use there
utility here the global ostasis
framework potentially allows us to
predict in the context of
epidemics uh we can talk about something
similar like I think the permutation
entropy uh framework helps us and what
I'll leave is with something very very
right with a concept this is my son and
he's a toddler okay anybody that's ever
been around a toddler knows predicting
what your child is going to be is a very
very important like that's kind of part
of what being a parent is right I have a
prediction that he's going to live with
me at 30 but you know by the way he acts
now but you never know now as as useful
as it would be for me to be able it's
very important you as useful as it would
be able to be for me to predict that
he's going to be quarterback for the
University of
Michigan it's actually much more useful
for me to be able to predict when he'll
be able to nap
tomorrow right right so the notion that
a long-term prediction is better or
holistic is better is just not true
right I think we should learn to be
right somewhat satisfi IED or in fact
goal shift to tuning our expectations in
particular with regards to time scale
for our predictions and that is right if
we have very very very very strong
predictive uh ability for tomorrow
that's actually acable that's not
actually any less rigorous technically
and it right and I think I think it
completely changes how we think about a
lot of these complex biological systems
um uh yeah
anyway great
[Applause]
that's Brandon uh thanks for a very
interesting to point out that that time
scale over which predictions are made
are is sort of fundamentally relevant uh
because um in public policy Frameworks
and context you know you need to make
decisions and it's fine to say for
astronomical systems right I can predict
two galaxies that will merge in 10 to
the seven years or whatever right so
yeah thanks for bringing that into Focus
uh
questions uh great thanks so much for
your very rich talk um yeah I just
wanted to maybe uh think together a bit
more just about constraints and the role
they play because it seems to me there's
kind of so so some people just think of
constraints as like additional causes or
stable causes you haven't measured I
guess my suspicion has always been that
they're much richer that's not just some
like causal variable that you could have
intervened on that you didn't include
but can be something I mean we have
historical constraints or long patterns
or sometimes you know these time scale
dependent behaviors it really feels more
like a fundamental characterization of
the system and there's no
translatability so I was just actually
try I'm really trying just to open up a
conversation about if you have a thought
about how to model constraints is it
just yeah no no thank you for that I
mean I think you know take a take a
problem like antibiotic resistance
Evolution which is something to think
about it's a complex problem it's an
evolutionary problem it's a molecular
problem it's a protein problem we
studied that problem from the angstrom
scale but when you think about kind of
the likelihood of evolving something
like that this is where
multidisciplinarity is essential it's
not just like fun to talk to people half
the problem is people's willingness to
take drugs on a certain schedule right
so if you are not in get that is a
constraint that the system H right that
is actually dictating the pace in the
direction of evolution of antimicrobial
resistance so I think I like your
definition in the sense of it's all I
mean it's all of the things and we don't
need to know all of them right right but
we need to know the ones that
meaningfully influence the Dynamics that
we're trying to predict and or right
establish causal change between so
that's I think about constraints and I
think the challenge is the silos right
we're just either we're not trained to
think very very broadly about some of
these other dimensions or we're
unwilling to do so or or we don't have
people who bring them together in this
sort of way and I think this is why um a
lot of my words
I've gained tremendously from being able
to open up that
dimensionality thank you um
sham the problem of uh prediction in
sociobiological systems like
epidemics where uh there's
a feedback loop uh you know prediction
itself uh
can cause uh conditions that will make
that prediction
untrue which is very different from Pure
physical system so on and yeah more than
anything I mean I think that's that's
true we see
that what do we do on how do we deal
with the problem of prediction soci
social
systems yeah no I mean again I'm not
believe I'm the not negative one about
these sorts of things in a lot of rooms
yeah I mean mathematical modeling has
got a lot of things right there are a
lot of conditions that it actually was
able to properly characterize or
understand and I think that is because
we had a proper understanding of what
the constraints were in that system so I
think we have an understanding of kind
of what the way that people interacting
and we understand what the constraints
are I think we have a lot of successful
iterations of where we've predicted the
trajectory of epidemics quite well um so
it's not a hopeless task it is just one
where our expectations need to be
modified by our understanding what the
constraints are that's what I would say
I mean and I guess um it also behooves
like continual updating of predictions
right so it's not even made a prediction
it's out there it's a very live process
Eduardo and then
Jan thank you Brandon I think I'm going
to follow up on on the conversation we
had yesterday
overnight what what makes me think a lot
we keep talking about understanding we
keep talking about knowledge and when
when I hear colleagues like you and
other colleagues who are much more at
the boundaries between applied and very
translational science more and more I
I'm asking myself who needs to
understand who needs to know because at
one level I feel like what at a time
where we feel like every citizen has to
understand how the vaccine works are
we're going to expect to understand how
that bridge that I'm going to cross with
a car was built and so so I don't think
I I think it's creating a lot of social
issues confusion problems that that have
really I mean affect us
all what are your thoughts on to I mean
is thinkable that at so many levels we
don't need everyone to understand we I
mean it used to be that I would go to
the doctor I mean you did a pregnancy
test you were not asking how does the
urine work with the strip Etc you assume
you were pregnant you moved
on and and my my worries is that again
in in the talking and and being those of
us some of us push to to do more and
more Outreach and it's getting all very
confusing and people don't know if
they're listening to the peer reviewer
to the peer viiew oral version of the
paper if they're listen to The Scientist
if they're listen to The Scientist
educator Citizen and I really think that
there's some positive aspects to the
science being siloed we can everyone
feels like they need to know where
understand but but not everyone has
spent 30 years looking at disase
transmission
yeah I mean I my opinion
is that's that that's a tough one right
so things are easier when they're Silo
and less Democratic in that way right
when there's less less input from the
public you know like well at least
there's a partition between experts and
nonexperts yeah when there's a partition
between I mean it's easier we don't have
to answer guess my job would be easier
if I did not feel like I was compelled
to communicate it with my grandmother
right it would right I would just be
able to do science and talk to you and
talk to you unfortunately that's not how
I think that's not where I think my job
is um so I I don't agree with that right
I'm actually deeply Pro democratization
of science I want a future where
citizens can actually participate in the
scientific process now we're a long way
from that that's utopian perhaps no but
also highly problematic right because
the sources of getting information now
and disinformation and misinformation
but it's problematic now even within
right it's not like we're doing the job
well right as professional scientists
there's misinformation now within
professional science there's there's
there's gatekeeping within professional
science there's discrimination within
professional science so I think we need
to stop looking at ourselves as a
paragon for the way that it works
because it doesn't it works for
us but fine I know a lot of people that
aren't but the way we think of democracy
is not having 300 million people voting
24/7 for every single thing that we do I
mean that's a referen it's not a
democracy and democracy I I used to I
used to defer to my doctor who in some
way I decided he knows and my dad told
me you ride the bike this way I didn't
decide to go figure it out myself so
there has to be some trust I understand
but I have fa my mother has faced
discrimination in the medical community
often and if she has did not have me
there to ask questions of the experts
growing up she would have had a shorter
life exactly so that's my point yeah
it's easier for me to trust the person
with the expertise and that would have
made it quicker and that would have made
it easier and the physician might have I
might have felt better about not having
to answer a question from a poor black
woman but the right thing to do was for
him to answer the questions that she had
about what the decision was being made
yeah I mean of course it's easier the
other way but it's wrong yeah no
absolutely and I think part of the issue
really is the you know with with the
openness comes certain kinds of risks
right so when we are not yet done
finishing our understanding or analysis
yes and we are sort of in process that
is now open to the public right and I
think that creates a lot of
possibilities so I think we have to
think very hard about how to
democratize and how to open up the
processes of science as inference really
right I mean because that's what that's
what the public really wants to know how
are you arriving at this conclusion when
you're giving me a directive I think
Samantha put it really nicely right that
even if you give the right information
decision making is really complex right
people may not actually use the uh they
may just go for the simplest version of
the information that you can provide
which may not be fully accurate right I
agree with both of you intensely um and
then also have work on discrimination in
medicine uh which is uh will lead to new
fears for everyone basically if you tell
your doctor things that they disagree
with they'll like you less um so great
seen it happen great news um but for me
it's more about this expectation that
like we should all be informed about
everything which is just humanly
impossible right you can't you can't
read up about every single decision you
want to make and that shouldn't be an
expectation we create for people but but
I feel like every time I we talk about
that we turn the dial up to well
everybody doesn't need to understand
everything in the universe and that's
not there's a lot of levels between
where we are now and that everything
like what I learned in the vaccine area
is people just wanted to know how it
worked once they learned how it worked
they went and took the VAC I get calls
to the St I get emails to this day
something I said on a podcast got their
whole family vaccinated because I just
took the time to explain like it's not
everybody wants to have access to
everything ever and we got this we're
going to be fighting for seats because
everybody in the community who thinks
they understand what causation means
that's not the reality and in fact the
reality that we create the that we've
created has created the war on science
right the silos of as created right the
substrate for society to distrust
science so we need to completely break
that and prove that and the question is
whether the inferential process should
be in full public view how much of it
should be in public view or whether it
should be in public view or not is a big
sort of question to debate
Janelle quickly go back to the point
that is it's a very different where
knowledge itself is indous know is
change what knowledge you have and the
way the knowledge feeds into the system
is effective and that means that you
can't stabilize the system as an object
of knowledge because everything you know
about is going to change system very
different set from traditional science
where we our out of the system and
deeply important exactly the
Realms thank you for that Tim this is
just a a short comment um in terms of I
understand this discussion and there's
certainly a big problem with
communicating science and motivating
people to behave the right way and to
say a lot of the problem arises from
within but you know let's not
ignore that the fossil fuel industry
undertook a billion dollar campaign to
misinform people that you know the the
tobacco industry undertook billion doll
campaigns to misinform people and with
the intentional effect to undermine
faith in science so I don't know that we
should blame our I mean we have our bits
of blame but yeah my question is what do
we do that's my question is is the so so
is the answer that because the fossil
fuel industry flooded the industry of
billions and misinformed the public and
I work on topics related that that I'm
not culpable to do anything about it is
that the
answer no no no you do something about
it you actually we should be the ones
going to war with these people this is
what happened with you Jen right I I
just the the other option is unconscious
I mean I but I think Tim is absolutely
right that they're having established
playbooks so at some level we have the
advantage post Hawk of knowing how these
misinformation and disinformation
campaigns can work and have worked and
in what ways they are successful and I
think the I mean I really like the
various threads that have come up right
um it is a conundrum right the if we are
able to uh show and reveal as expert
scientists or people working with data
sets and inferring from data sets
whatever be those data sets even if that
process is fully demystified it's
unclear because you have these other
outside forces that are sort of banging
at the door so the question is given
that is the
reality um is talking about how we
relate effects and causes
and how we arrive at decisions and how
individuals then incorporate that
information and make decisions it's a
very complex space right uh but I think
we all share responsibility to do
something about
it okay one two and
three I want to go to coffee so I want
to be attentive to that yes thank you
this is fascinating uh conversation
um and at the expense of opening a can
of
worms um better be a small can very very
small can very small can called AI um
and um my question is would it if if and
when we have trustworthy reliable robust
products and services AI products and
services will that help democ
democratize science for example your
would have instead of asked you and took
you with her to the doctors she could
have had her phone and asked you know an
AI uh special specialized
product what do I what do I what do I do
with the doctor what do I tell the
doctor I I'll just ere by saying I find
myself oddly Pro technology in a lot of
these conversations relative to my
friends right I having seen when you
seen seen discrimination happen in
person you don't I'm just not sure that
that's a I'm not sure that the
algorithmization of it is is is worse
right but I mean the question is I'm not
convinced right no but Brandon but if
the algorithm has been has been aring
that with biased of course tra totally
right it's going to be no better no no
no totally right I'm just I just don't
have faith in people like that
right so a question there quick question
okay great okay thank you all okay maybe
we just wrap it up and head up to
[Applause]
coffee